this is a Fox News Alert the Trump
administration is on the brink but you
didn't see this coming of resuming u.s.
funding of the World Health Organization
last month you'll remember the
administration cut off u.s. funding at
the president's direction that amounts
to about 400 million a year they did
this as the president explained because
the World Health Organization badly
mishandled and lied about the krona
virus pandemic and of course
nauseatingly subservient to the
government of China but tonight this
program has obtained a draft letter that
would partly restore that funding
we're told the president supposedly has
agreed to sign the letter if he hasn't
already been interesting to know who
convinced him to do that the letter says
in part quote despite its shortcomings I
believe that the World Health
Organization still has tremendous
potential and I want to see the whu-oh
live up to that this potential
particularly now during this global
crisis that is why I've decided the
United States will continue to partner
and work with the World Health
Organization and agree to pay up to what
China pays in assessed contributions end
quote so if this does happen if the
State Department gets its way and the
u.s. does match the contribution that
China kicks in every year we still won't
have the influence that China has no one
will but we'd spend about 1/10 of what
we were contributing before we'll
continue to follow this story now there
are certainly many reasons that the
president was deeply skeptical the World
Health Organization in the first place
and stopped funding it stretcher Tedrow
said Hannam has thoroughly disgraced
himself in his organization for four
years but particularly throughout this
coronavirus epidemic you remember the
World Health Organization attacked
travel restrictions global restrictions
is unnecessary and needles to say racist
they then spread the baldest kind of
Chinese propaganda that the virus could
not spread person-to-person that killed
people and now according to recent
reports Ted Rose took direct orders from
the government of China and delayed
calling the virus a pandemic when it
clearly was and yet there is one person
who has long always through thick and
thin been a fervent fan of Ted Rose and
that's dr. Anthony foul G so Ted Rose is
really an outstanding person I've known
from the time that he was the Minister
of Health of Ethiopia I mean obviously
over the years anyone who says that the
w-h-o has not had problems has not been
watching the w-h-o but I think under his
leadership they've done very well he has
been all over this I was on the phone
with him a few hours ago leading a w-h-o
call well doubtless dr. Faraj who will
be thrilled with tonight's news that
were gonna continue to fund the World
Health Organization by the way that time
in Ethiopia that he's gushing I've known
him since he was in Ethiopia
that's when Ted Rose was helping to
cover up multiple cholera outbreaks for
political reasons not really what you
want in a World Health Organization
director but what we have